Narrator:
UTILIZING 187 ROLLS OF DUCT TAPE
TO MAKE 2,000 FEET OF ROPE
AND A CANOPY OF 500 SQUARE FEET.
IT'S BEEN
A MONUMENTAL UNDERTAKING.
Adam:
BUSTER'S OFF THE GROUND.
AND THIS
IS THE MOMENT OF TRUTH.
WILL A DUCT TAPE PARACHUTE...
THREE...
...SAVE YOUR LIFE?
...TWO, ONE, GO.
HE'S RELEASED.
IT'S OPENING.
-IT OPENED!
-OH, MY GOD.
-OH!
-IT'S OPEN!
-OH, MY GOODNESS.
-OH, MY GOSH!
Narrator: INCREDIBLY, BUSTER
LOOKS LIKE HE'S GONNA MAKE IT.
-OH!
-THERE WE GO.
THE DUCT TAPE
PARACHUTE IS WORKING?
♪♪
-OH, MY GOODNESS.
-OH, MY GOD!
-OH. OH.
-OH, OH, OH, OH.
OH, NO.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THAT WAS UGLY.
♪♪
Valerie: WE JUST DID OUR
DUCT TAPE PARACHUTE TEST,
AND, MAN.
Elijah:
DO YOU THINK BUSTER SURVIVED?
Valerie:
NO, I THOUGHT HE WAS EITHER
GONNA GO PERFECTLY OR HORRIBLY
AND BOTH THINGS HAPPENED.
OH, OH, OH, OH!
IT WAS AWESOME.
I'M NOT GETTING A PULSE.
Adam:
SO I WANT TO CONFIRM ON THAT
LAST DROP THAT BUSTER DIED.
HE LANDED AT ABOUT
28 MILES PER HOUR
WHICH IS EQUIVALENT
TO FALLING OUT OF
A FOURTH-
OR FIFTH-STORY WINDOW.
SOME PEOPLE IN HISTORY
HAVE SURVIVED SUCH A DROP.
MOST DON'T.
BUT THAT DROP DID YIELD
ONE PIECE
OF VERY COMPELLING DATA,
AND THAT IS,
ONCE THE CHUTE OPENED,
AND IT WAS SUCCESSFULLY OPENED,
EVEN IF IT WAS FOR
A BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME,
THE SPEED AT WHICH
BUSTER WAS DESCENDING
WAS 13 MILES PER HOUR.
PRECISELY THE NUMBER
THAT VALERIE'S MATH SAID
HE SHOULD BE FALLING AT.
I WISH
WE COULD DO IT AGAIN.
ACTUALLY THERE'S NO REASON
THAT WE CAN'T DO IT AGAIN.
YOU GUY'S WANT TO GO
FOR ANOTHER RUN?
-YES.
-EXCELLENT!
THIS MIGHT ACTUALLY WORK.
I GOT TO TELL YOU --
I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED.